negarse a llevar el velo en Irán sigue
siendo peligroso Aunque cada vez más
mujeres lo hacen en este vídeo difundido
en las redes sociales se ve a dos
mujeres en una tienda una de ellas sin
velo siendo confrontadas por otro
cliente el hombre les echa yogur en el
pelo por no respetar el código de
vestimenta religioso la justicia emitió
una orden de detención contra el hombre
por agresión y contra las dos mujeres
por no llevar el propietario de la
tienda por su lado recibió una
advertencia tras el incidente el
presidente Ibrahim Racing recordó que
llevara el velo es una obligación
si hay personas que no comparten nuestra
creencia entonces Este es un lugar para
que los centros científicos y culturales
así como las escuelas la disputan y las
convenzan de usarlo porque es una
prioridad para nosotros
Pero lo importante es que hoy tenemos un
mandato legal este obliga a todos a
cumplir la ley desde la muerte de maxa
mini en septiembre tras su detención por
no respetar el código de vestimenta y
las protestas que la siguieron un número
creciente de mujeres desafía al régimen
y Camina sin público muchas también
comparten este tipo de video en las
redes sociales Estas mujeres se
arriesgan a ser detenidas y a
intimidaciones en las últimas semanas la
autoridad judicial anunció que podría
votar una nueva ley para hacer respetar
la obligación para las mujeres de llevar
El hip hop incluiría penas adicionales
como el cierre de su lugar de trabajo o
el exilio varios cafés y restaurantes ya
cerraron por haber acogido a mujeres sin
velo